because they were spending like you know
3 million a month on AWS something crazy
okay couple things I thought were
interesting one you use you posted
something about this thing called mode
points what is that me yeah did you post
something about moe points no what is no
points it's just I thought it's your
friend who's doing it it's basically
like oh my friend yet lo yes he just
launched it yeah Moe my friend Moe okay
so what it is is yeah I was like what
the heck I didn't even remember the name
my friend Moe helps people with points
that's funny he'll love that we're
talking about so Moe points so Moe it's
my friend Moe him and Ramone grew up
together in Moe's from Afghanistan by
way of where's Ramon from Netherlands
and then moved here and they used to
have a business it's shut down now so I
could talk about it where they would buy
and sell airline points and he became an
expert on how to maximize points and so
I'm getting into this now and so for
example if there's all these ways that
you can like spending money on
advertising on this on that you can
maximize your points and fly for free
forever for years and so he would teach
me how to do it myself and I was like
whoa don't listen to a course and so
that's what it is let's let's let's pick
them out though is it moe points com Moe
points com yeah I checked it out cuz I
was pretty interested in this like in
the same way that you want like a tax
guy to help you save money on the back
end you know whenever you do likes
pretty significant credit card spending
and a lot of times if you own your own
business you can rack up a lot of
spending on credit cards I hate going
and figuring this stuff out I just feel
like it's a waste of my brain and it's a
waste of my time together like optimize
my spending and buy points that I can
travel free and all this stuff but I
think no it's valuable and so I was
hoping to get like what's the shortcut
what's the like you know either you do
it for me or like what's the 80/20 give
me the few things I can do that will
give me the highest return on my time
and effort because I know I'm sort of
wasting this opportunity and I don't
want to go
I'm an expert in the stuff but if you're
an expert fantastic so I signed up for
it oh great I make sure he knows so you
know points are interesting I just got
into him recently so I earn maybe
300,000 to 400,000 points a month and
that translates to 1% of that in cash
value so if I spent a million dollars a
year I'm through my credit card which
sounds like a lot if you're just an
individual and that is a lot if you're
an individual but your business that's
nothing
I get $100,000 cash back now here's the
cool thing that cash back in most cases
is tax-free so in if you live in San
Francisco that's the equivalent of
getting a salary of 180 grand or a
hundred job yeah and so it's great and
so I've actually met some entrepreneurs
who are I think you can get up to three
hundred sixty thousand dollars some of
the count was gonna like tweet at me and
say I got it wrong but I'm almost
positive and it's controversial I'm
almost positive being up to $3,000 in
cash back and so I know this one lady
who's got this flour company and she
gets three hundred fifty thousand
dollars in cash back income a year yeah
that's great I have a friend who he
basically negotiate with his investors
he's like I'd like to pay the AWS bill
for my company on my personal credit
card and so he earned like whatever Amex
double black platinum gold whatever it
is like the highest tier for life
because they were spending like you know
three million a month on AWS something
crazy and so like he's like oh if I ever
want to fly I fly first-class now I get
like three equinoxes I get free this I
get free that because that's the person
like the highest tier of Amex and he's
like yeah I got lifetime because during
my company I just asked can I just put
this on this card and keep that you know
tied to my name and they didn't and so
and so that's what most trying to do now
it's just like a course and hand
hand-to-hand combat like consultation
we're trying to help people but that is
kind of interesting to like log in to a
portal and or like technology and it
does it for you that is pretty amazing
and and your transaction fee is either
upfront fee or you take a you skim a
little that is incredibly interesting
you
[Music]
[Applause]